oh yeah welcome to fry diary my diary to
look back my weekend vlog for him here
are some of the stuff that happened to
me this week I'm in Philadelphia right
now but I started this week in Australia
normal check it out
oh hey memory is loving Tyler's [ __ ]
we have arrived in Sydney and thank you
to the ladies of their politic recess
with Tim town and this bag of super
Ozymandias this will be our lunch before
the show thank you very much they're the
main town you shouldn't think you [ __ ]
up
someone is enjoying their Tim Tam yeah
these are more like shame I am oh yes
that's a good look good look how big I
just got into my hotel room in Sydney
and it's awesome
look at this place come on what what are
you wow wow wow
what even are you oh wow I could do work
and look at the place that I'm gonna
future sleep and then Oh what excuse you
what oh wow okay well yeah woo hallo
slide are you a slide go we just get to
the venue we're backstage at the Sydney
theatre and it's the most beautiful
backstage area I think we've ever been
in look at this hole there's this
there's this room this looks like a
hotel there's this beautiful living our
dining room table is all of this space
is a feed to the stage and this is our
dressing room which is insane look at
this beauty and you look this beautiful
Australian alright let's go see the
stage well Hannah blocks
I'm just looking how Hannah block
this is so cool okay hair some hair and
some makeup is done and now we were
headed to the meet and greet infinite
repeat gonna suck up it's a family meal
before the show okay we're prepping for
the show doing lots of business things
much business very professional and
because there's a live feed to the
theatre they just opened the house so we
can see all of you guys walking in and
taking your seats in front of the stage
we can even see some of you taking
selfies of yourself in front of the
stage ha ha ha ha ha ha this is how I
feel all the time just cause some
paranoia that someone's watching me
yeah
this is doc is helping us in Sydney and
she's the goddamn bass oh we just
finished the finish Benny with great
this good news quick Sydney is what you
would call way over there exhaust 60
ounces we truly did
that was amazing shell Thank You Sydney
you are all super lovely and sweet my
arms are like shaking because of the
tiredness and like the adrenaline dump
that just happened sting them dumb ok
get back oh my god this is beautiful
this is so beautiful Daphne and Simon
took us here after the show and it's
incredibly beautiful look at these two
BFFs yeah believe it can you believe it
and then last but not least did a lot of
fun detention mission 11:02 of us out by
1107 I got this shirt it says I don't
know if I feel about it because it says
risk everything lose nothing and that
seems unrealistic
laughter Brisbane but before we leave
for Brisbane
two-thirds of us did some damage Topshop
supermarket sweep style yo mam I gotta
cross me today haha we are at the
Brisbane venue we just got here before
the meeting great and we're gonna see
the stage let's look at the stage wow
look at this
how cool okay we're getting ready to go
to the Brisbane mangry before the show
you're making look what just women just
full of it and I fell it's not so much a
dress well when you're looking in the
mirror and watching her do that okay
let's go to this meet and greet people
look at these was it Tilly was her
name's Tilly made us easily I know this
is us and it's supposed to recreate the
photo that we took at VidCon two years
ago at our camp Takota booth with the
magnifying glass and the butterfly net
and how did Tilly know I have such a
friend buck
Kabam we made it to the venue and Perth
look at all these pillows so many
pillows member yes Hannah we're gonna go
check out the stage for the first time
let's go see it look at all of it
cool okay now we're going to our very
last me greet a purse what's on the
stage
oh my god
the real they're real okay Hannah cutter
sleeves off but cut them too long that's
just some memory is going to attempt
with a tiny baby stapler to staple them
and make them more appropriate because
this is a family show 15 minutes before
the last show how's everyone feeling 44
great you go great but more importantly
stepdad hey shrimp biscuit how you
feeling how you feeling 15 minutes
before last show I'm feeling very
watermelon
what I usually very water melancholy
thank you what a great step that I
didn't I just say that my favorite part
of this whole tour has really truly
honestly been bringing walked over back
okay no it really has been also Simon
one shrimp is get seven six to get that
promo
I am back in the United States and I am
doing some last-minute Christmas
shopping it is the 23rd of December the
day before Christmas Eve and tomorrow
morning I'm getting on a plane to New
Jersey
Walter Philadelphia to see my family for
the holiday so I'm doing some
last-minute Christmas shopping how fun
it's like 10:30 at night I just bought
myself a bright yellow suitcase to bring
gifts back because good morning this
Christmas Day and I'm in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania in a hotel um because my
parents live in New Jersey very close to
Philadelphia and I got in very late last
night so I stayed in a hotel
look here silly Oh Billy cool hello you
look like a city so just get it ready
now and going over to my mom's house for
Christmas to give them present
Oh all of these presents as presents in
here I also ordered a bunch of presents
I got delivered to my mom's house that I
have to go wrap up and I'm very excited
because one of my favorite things in the
world to do is give people present you
it's very selfish it seems like that's
like oh what I like beautiful feeling
that's actually very selfish um I just
once before we consider me thoughtful
well that's it for this Friday re I hope
you guys enjoyed it I will be sharing
all the Christmas festivities with you
guys in next week's Friday re so to all
of those that celebrate Christmas and
any other sort of celebratory thing
around this time of year
happy that I don't know